we are following breaking news from  Crimea where Russian officials now say a  student opened fire at a vocational  College this morning at least 18 people  are dead including the gunman  officials say the attack happened in the  ancient city of Kerch in Crimea a former  Ukrainian territory occupied by Russia  most of the victims reportedly our  students Roxana Saberi is following this  story from London and brings us the  latest Roxana good morning what can you  tell us Russian investigators say at  least 18 people were killed and more  than 40 others injured they have now  identified a suspect they say 18 year  old vladislav Ross Lee akov entered the  College with a rifle and opened fire  before killing himself they say all the  victims died of gunshot wounds both  students and staff are believed to be  among the dead President Putin took part  in a moment of silence and said that the  motivation for the attack would be  carefully studied Nora  all right Roxana thank you